Um, how about this? This is interesting fighting news,
but it's it's it's this news just broke and, uh,
it's good that we got Sergio Chacone, uh,
ex X-Box yo Jake Paul is going to fight Connor McGregor.
Is that that's that that can be signed, sealed. They're ready to go yet.
Pimpy says yes.
He's in talks with them. I don't know if that's, you know what,
that probably will go down. One thing that people have to realize now,
if you're like a boxing purists or martial art purist, listen,
this is the future of fighting right now. It's going to definitely,
uh, have its own lane and continue to go on this way.
There's too much money involved and there's too many people tuning in.
So I wouldn't be surprised if that fight goes on and you know what it be as
attending as hell. These guys are both show men. Uh,
and it'd be fun to watch just as we've witnessed this past weekend.
I personally didn't like to see Nate Robinson gets stretched out like that.
I felt bad for him. He signed the paper. He knew what he was in for,
or maybe he didn't know where he was at four. Do you think,
do you think with all your boxing experience,
you could win in a fight against Nate Robinson, Nate Robinson, aquaponic Wolf,
Jake, Paul, Paul Young man. And he's like,
he's fell. He fell in love with the sport. Yeah. And he's only 23 years old yet.
Like he can actually be a for real boxer. Yeah. I mean, you know, listen,
I could, I could apply. I could probably, uh, do my thing for, you know,
a few rounds, but his conditioning man, he's 21 years old. He might,
he might now let me, let me ask you this. Let me ask you this. Obviously,
you know, boxing inside and out.
If Jake Paul was to fight an actual professional boxer,
would he get like his head like ripped off?
Like I think, I think he, uh,
would lose against most pro boxers.
Uh,
but any athletes such as Nate Robinson or any other youth?
Super. I think he got smashed something about his balance and his, uh,
his athleticism. It's very surprising to me.
He's a big guy who started boxing just two years ago. It's pretty impressive.
The way he moves. So you think,
you think he could actually beat some professional boxes right now? You know,
it depends what level of, you know,
anyone can be a professional boxer for people don't know that. Like,
why don't you put your money up, then son do it for your family.
You're breaking up. I can't hear you. I said, put your money up.
Why don't you do it for your family? You know,
you're the only dude I've ever met in my life that the Santa hat is tight on his
head. Yo Matt point, the KKK in the hat like that,
somebody in the chat said, Sergeant likes the most dirt bag ELLs.
I got cocaine right here and less than the rim.
Hey everybody, it's the Bay Ridge boys. First of all,
what a welcome you to our Patrion page, take a look around,
very happy to have you. You're going to enjoy it. We have a $5 level.
A $10 level, $25, a hundred dollars. I mean, we go wild here at this patron.
So this is really, really, really where the wild laughs happened.
This is the kind of stuff you can't hear it unless it was pre 2016.
That's what it is. So joy early access for episodes,
you can listen to first $5 gets you all the audio content. We do.
$10 gets you all the video content we do and tons of other bonus
content or our higher tiers. Enjoy you. Take.